- It blows my mind every time I
do those things where people are
like, "Oh, you're nice and
you really like your fans."
I'm like, "Yes,
what's the alternative?"
They're like,
"Oh, everybody else."
And it just so crazy to me.
It's crazy to me,
please, so many of you,
so many of you,
that's not true.
A couple of you
are gonna break out,
follow this blueprint,
win, become something.
Have people admire
you and care about you,
want to take a selfie,
want to get the book signed.
Please, please don't become that
person that ever
takes it for granted.
Remember where you came from.
It really matters.
Never, never ever lose that
gratitude of another even if you
have four people
following you right now.
Never lose the
gratitude for those four.
And I think it's very easy and
so that's kind of a
memorable moment, DRock.
How many people wanted to be
in line after watching me talk
for an hour or answer questions
wanted to stay in line for an
hour and a half to get a selfie.
Are you kidding me?
That's the greatest
high in the world.